batteriebetriebene Lampen sind in der
Ukraine in diesen Tagen der Renner seit
Russlands wiederholten Attacken auf die
kritische Infrastruktur wollen sich die
Menschen unabhängig machen von der
Stromversorgung das Geld für viele
andere Produkte haben sie in den
Markthallen von Odessa kaum noch
schlecht für die Händler angesichts
gestörte Lieferketten durch den Krieg
haben sie es schwer ihre Produkte
woanders zu verkaufen
es ist sehr schwierig für die Leute
viele sind weggegangen andere kaufen nur
noch wenige 100 Gramm meines Käses die
haben oft nur noch Kleingeld im
Portemonnaie
die Geldautomaten geben nicht genug
Bares zum Beispiel für den Kauf von
diesen heimischen Karpfen weil nach
russischen Angriffen oft nicht nur der
Strom ausfällt sondern auch die
Internetverbindung zu den Banken oder
aber weil es ersparte längst schon
aufgebraucht ist
die Preise steigen ständig das kann sich
kaum noch jemand leisten wir machen nur
noch ein Drittel des früheren Umsatzes
ganz besonders betroffen von Russlands
Attacken auf die kritische Infrastruktur
ist der Großraum Kiew mit seinen 1,3
Millionen Menschen Bürgermeister
Klitschko will am Mittag auf einer
Konferenz in Brüssel um ausländische
Investitionen werden für den
Wiederaufbau seiner Stadt wir denken
sehr optimistisch und wir haben Pläne
statt wieder aufzubauen und statt zu
entwickeln und
deswegen wir sind bereit sehr viele
Projekte zu präsentieren an unsere
Partner und sehr dankbar an unsere
Partner für Unterstützung
die Regierung in Kiew die Weltbank und
die EU-Kommission gehen für die
Beseitigung der Kriegsschäden in ganzen
Land von rund 350 Milliarden Euro aus
es gibt also viel zu besprechen mit dem
neuen ukrainischen Botschafter in
Deutschland seit dem 24 Oktober ist
olexi mackayef im Amt offiziell
eingeführt hier sehen wir die Bilder von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier
47 Jahre alt hat internationale
Beziehungen studiert unter anderem im
Außenministerium der Ukraine gearbeitet
und war Sonderbeauftragter für die
Sanktionen gegen Russland als
Botschafter Dritter in große Fußstapfen
denn sein Vorgänger andre Melnik war
bekannt für meinungsstarke Äußerungen
Melk setzte sich seit Beginn der des
Kriegs in der Ukraine unter anderem für
mehr Waffenlieferung aus Deutschland ein
und jetzt ist er bei uns der neue
Botschafter der Ukraine in Deutschland
herzlich willkommen im Botschafter guten
Morgen wir haben ihren Vorgänger gerade
gesehen der war sehr bekannt hier in der
Öffentlichkeit auch weil er immer wieder
sehr forscht auch und diplomatisch
gesprochen hat manchmal hat er sich im
Ton vergriffen was für ein Botschafter
wollen sie sein
ich bin sehr aufgeschlossen aber auch
direkt in Gesprächen mit Partnern mein
Anliegen ist Vertrauen aufzubauen und
die aufrecht zu erhalten weil im
Vertrauen eigentlich sehen wir eine gute
Möglichkeit dass wir uns einander
unterstützen und wir brauchen diese
Unterstützung von Deutschland sehr vor
allem jetzt im Winter wir haben gerade
die Bilder gesehen aus der Ukraine und
den Bericht äh es ist in vielen Teilen
des Landes ein schwieriges Situation
teilweise fällt der Strom aus durch die
russischen Angriffe keine Heizung was
ist ihre Einschätzung wie will und wie
wird die Ukraine durch den Winter kommen
wir sind ein sehr kämpferisches Volk wir
wir kommen jetzt zusammen und
ich habe versucht jetzt auf am
Wochenende meine Eltern zu erreichen
klappt es sehr schlecht mit der
Verbindung
und so drei vier Stunden am Tag gibt es
Strom in Kiew in vielen Häuser gibt es
kaum kaum Heizung aber trotzdem wir sind
wir sind uns sicher dass wir diesen
Krieg gewinnen müssen was braucht die
Ukraine jetzt auch von Deutschland um
gut durch diesen Winter zu kommen heute
wird sehr viel davon gesprochen dass den
den Menschen geholfen werden muss und
wir brauchen
Generatoren und
autotransformatoren die von russischen
Raketenangriffen besonders betroffen
sind
aber auch müssen wir
die
Gründe
von von diesen schwierigen von dieser
schwierigen Situation
mal bekämpfen und das ist
russische Angriffe deswegen bräuchten
wir
Luftabwehrsysteme und Waffen um uns
und den Frieden in Europa zu schützen
damit meinen sie ja auch schwere Waffen
konkret geht es jetzt um die Diskussion
des Schützenpanzers des Kampfpanzers
Leopard 2 den sie gefordert haben die
Bundesregierung zögert da der
Bundeskanzler hat immer wieder betont es
soll keine Alleingänge geben und
Kritiker sagen damit werde ja der Krieg
eskaliert und Russland könnte sich damit
weiter provoziert fühlen wir brauchen
Waffen weil deutsche war von retten
Leben und nur dass das Beispiel des
deutschen flugabwehrsystems Iris t äh
welches von Deutschland
früher in die Ukraine geliefert worden
war zeigen sich sehr gut in unseren
kämpfen und viele russischen
Marschflugkörper würden von diesem Tee
abgefangen das heißt weniger
zivilienstraße Infrastruktur getroffen
weniger Tote in der Ukraine und auch
weitere
auf Geräte wie Schützenpanzer und Panzer
brauchen wir wir sind jetzt mit mit der
Bundesregierung in vertrauensvollen
Dialog darüber wir brauchen Waffen um
diesen Krieg zu gewinnen das betonen sie
immer wieder haben sie auch in ihren
ersten Interviews hier in Deutschland
gesagt das Ziel der Ukraine ist es
diesen Krieg zu gewinnen aber was
bedeutet das genau unsere territorin
zurück zu erobern Russland immer noch
besetzt über 15 Prozent des Territoriums
der Ukraine meinen sie damit die
Territorien vor dem Angriff im Februar
ich meine das ganze Territorium der
Ukraine das heißt Donalds Glurak und
auch Creme weil das gehört zur
völkerrechtlichen territoren vorher
wollen sie sich nicht mit den Russen an
einen Tisch setzen
wollen überhaupt nicht an dich setzen
weil wenn man von den Verhandlungen
spricht und wir haben diese
Verhandlungen schon viele Male
vorgeschlagen russische Antwort darauf
neue
Raketenangriffe noch einen einen eine
andere Frage zu einem anderen Punkt der
Bundestag will heute Mittag eine
Resolution zu der vom sowjetiktator
Stadion verursachten Hungersnot
holodumor in der Ukraine vor 90 Jahren
verabschieden hier sehen wir auch ein
paar Bilder dieser gezielt
herbeigeführten Hungersnot sind
Schätzungen zufolge mindestens 4
Millionen Menschen in der Ukraine zum
Opfer gefallen der russische Präsident
bestreitet nach wie vor dass es sich
dabei um einen Genozid handelt das soll
in dieser Resolution des Bundestags
heute so formuliert und entschieden
werden wie bewerten Sie diese geplante
Resolution des deutschen Parlaments ist
das wichtig für Sie und für die Ukraine
das ist wichtig für für uns und das sagt
noch mal dass das im Deutschen Bundestag
ein überparteiliche
[Musik]
Resolution überparteilicher Antrag ins
Leben gerufen wird und wir sehen dass
eigentlich all die demokratischen
Parteien im Deutschen Bundestag stehen
hinter der Ukraine
holodomore ist wichtig als als Teil der
Erinnerung Erinnerungspolitik der
Ukraine und übrigens an an dem Tag wo UK
als Ukraine die Veranstaltung und zum 90
jahrestag des
veranstaltet hat haben wir auch aus der
Ukraine mit Hilfe von unseren Partner im
Rahmen des grain from you Crain
Programms viele Schiffe mit ukrainischem
Getreide in die armen Länder Afrikas
geschickt und auch Bundeskanzler war
Teil dieses dieses grain von Ukraine
Summit am an diesem Samstag Ukraine
macht auch die Welt sicherer und
Ernährungssicherheit gehört auch zu
unseren wichtigen Prioritäten
sagte neue Botschafter der Ukraine hier
in Deutschland olexi marquef zum ersten
Mal bei uns im ZDF Morgenmagazin vielen
Dank dass Sie heute Morgen habe
Dankeschön danke